foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
tonight on Piers Morgan on Center the
king's welcome for zielinski as he
rallies Parliament and back Ukraine to
victory for as President Biden snubs a
warn instead of the Union speech could
Ukraine's next big battle be the one for
America's continued support well my
guest tonight might know she's the
rising star of the Republican Party one
of the most controversial politicians in
America today Kerry Lake could be number
two to a future president Trump tonight
she joins me live
plus now even God goes gender neutral
the Church of England are based
non-gender pronouns for his Almighty I'm
sorry they're Almighty we'll debate
whether they've lost their minds
from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
well good evening London welcome to
Piers Morgan uncensored more than 11 000
people have now died in a devastating
earthquake that rocked turkey in Syria
this week that's 11 000 grieving
families 11 000 stories of harrowing
life-changing grief stories are
suffering like Mesa Hansen a Turkish
father pictured hold in the hand of his
dead fifteen-year-old daughter with the
wreckage of their home and their lives
piled around him
the rescue missions in Turkey are
swinging into action but they've been
too slow the Turkish presidents now
admitted that one of the first countries
to send Aid was Ukraine it's facing its
own daily nightmare of grief and
suffering and the blood-soed hands of
Putin but Ukraine is first in line to
help turkey because the bit of Truth is
they've become experts in pulling people
out of rubble it's a great credit to
president zielinski who's fighting for
the survival of his country that he
didn't hesitate to jump to turkey's
rescue and it's a great credit to both
the United States and Britain that we've
been shoulder to shoulder with Ukraine
in this war at some point zelenski may
very clearly in his address to
Parliament today in only a second
International visit since the start of
the war
we know Russia will lose
and we we really know the victory the
victory will change the world
and this will be a change that the world
has long needed
the United Kingdom
is marching with us towards the most I
think the most important victory of our
lifetime it will be a victory over the
very idea of the war
after we went together any aggressor it
doesn't matter big or small will know
what awaits him if he attacks
International order
it was a magnificent speech by one of
the most inspiring leaders in the world
right now and he's right isn't he this
is a war the whole world needs him to
win Britain's rightly given a lot to
Ukraine should give even more the United
States has given more to Ukraine than
the rest of the world combined Ukraine
couldn't have held off Russia for this
long without America's support but when
President Biden gave instead of the
Union Address last night and Kramer's
barely mentioned it's thousands of miles
away but Ukraine's next battle may be in
Congress to attain America's fulsome
support Biden's got an eye on next
year's election where aged 81 nearly two
actually maybe well be it may well have
to run for president again a powerful
faction in the Republican party which
Now controls Congress believes that aids
should be cut back that America should
put America first people often scream
about International Aid and question why
we do it we'll look no further than the
suffering of the people of Ukraine look
no further than the people in turkey and
Syria and the stories of grieving
fathers like Meza hanser that's why we
do it
well joining me now is Carrie late she
was a republican nominee for Arizona
governor one of the leading lights in
the making America great again movement
and being touted by some pundits as
president Trump's running mate in 2024
well Karen like welcome to Piers Morgan
uncensored
it's so wonderful to be with you today
Pierce so we've never spoken but I've
watched you with Fascination from afar
not least because for a long time you
were doing what I'm doing you were
anchoring the news and you did that for
many years so my first question is what
on Earth possessed you to want to give
up a lovely job like this to get into
the there what can often be a hell hole
of political life
you mean why would I leave the news to
to jump into the swamp
um that is a good question and and I did
love my career for 30 years I was a
broadcast journalist and I love
um digging into issues learning about
them telling people stories but during
covid I really had an epiphany a wake-up
call that what was being pushed by the
news the mainstream corporate news was
half truths and fear tactics and really
was just dividing our country and I
could no longer lend my my heart and my
soul and my voice and my reputation to
putting out half truths I wasn't
interested in that so I did a lot of
soul searching and praying and and I
walked away from my career my very
successful career in 22 years as number
one news anchor in Arizona I walked away
from a massive paycheck and I just said
God I'm putting my life in your hands
take me where you want me and the
amazing people of Arizona reached out
they were so moved by what I I did that
they reached out to me and said would
you please run for office we need
somebody who understands us understands
our state our issues and will absolutely
represent us and so I reluctantly went
into politics I didn't even know how to
run for office I had to call the Arizona
Republican party and say how do you run
for office I mean I'm I'm really at the
heart of it just a mom who is concerned
about where our state is going and so
that's how I ended up running for office
little did I know that we would lead an
amazing movement here in the state
bringing in Independence Democrats and
Republicans to bring about change here
in Arizona and and secure our streets
and secure our border unfortunately the
election didn't go the way uh that we
wanted to because we have a lot of fraud
in our elections and and we're working
through that right now okay
well that was a good pitch but let me
just put a butt in the into the works
there because I'm curious about a lot of
of course a lot of things have happened
to you in your life where you've made
quite dramatic changes and I want to
just talk to you about them for example
you used to be a Buddhist According to
some of your friends but now you're
Christian you before Trump's
Inauguration in 2017 you posted an
anti-trump post now you're one of the
big trumpers you were very supportive of
John McCain after he died and called him
courageous and the hero and then you
turned on him you were a republican you
became an independent you then became a
Democrat you're now a republican again
so your critics would say come on Carol
who is the real Carrier Lake here you're
flip-flopping all over the place on all
businesses
you're throwing a lot at me so let me
hit all of that I am a woman of Christ
and a woman of faith I grew up Lutheran
and Catherine a Catholic growing up I'm
now an Evangelical and I think that
there's something you can Garner from
every religion in the world and I and
the Buddhists are peaceful and I think
it's absolutely wonderful uh you know
I've been very much into yoga in my life
and so I don't have a problem with any
religion of the world and wherever you
can find something that stirs your soul
and gives you peace in this difficult
time I think that's wonderful I find
that in the Bible and I am a Christian
and a Evangelical Christian and I I
don't judge anybody by their religion
I've never made an a negative post about
President Trump at all I don't know what
you're talking about and I would it
would challenge you well it was a
Facebook advice
let me clarify it was a Facebook post
we're showing it on screen it was one
that you posted to your Facebook which
was right on the eve of the inauguration
and after Fox News revealed this
apparently it then got taken down but it
was not my president and it was it was
pleased I've never taken anything down
from my I've never taken anything down
from my Facebook post and I've never
printed anything uh derogatory toward
president Trump as a journalist it was
not my job to post anything derogatory
about the president I would often talk
about something happening in the news
and say hey what do you think this is
happening and this is happening what are
your thoughts that's how I use social
media as a journalist and I think that's
a really healthy way to use social media
where you get people kind of socializing
and discussing issues on social media
I've always been a supporter of
President Trump but I didn't feel the
need to put that out publicly as a
journalist you really should keep your
ideas in check I also covered the
mccains and I covered everybody fairly I
it's not my it's not my job as a
journalist to tell somebody how to think
about that
read the post read the post for me well
I challenge you to read the posts as
well here's what I would say about John
McCain is that I I knew him I
interviewed him many times I had huge
admiration for him and it seemed after
he died you shared all that admiration
you called him courageous and heroic and
so on uh but then read the post but then
in your
campaigning about him and you you said
that Arizona produced a lot of losers so
people took that to mean John McCain
right
well I can't help if people think that I
mean that's kind of a silly thing to
think I covered John McCain I have
immense respect for his military career
you know he was a politician here for 40
years I covered him for many of that
many of those years and no politician is
free from criticism of their of their
work I mean I look at president Trump he
was criticized day in and out for you
know 24 hours a day seven days a week
and he's still being criticized even
though he's a private citizen we can
definitely criticize our politicians and
the work they do I know that that uh
that Senator McCain promised and I
covered him probably longer than you did
Pierce to uh end Obamacare replace it
with something better when he had the
opportunity and that fell squarely on
his shoulders he went in and gave the
thumbs down and didn't do what he
promised the people of Arizona
when he was running for uh Senate one of
the times that he was running for
re-election he did an ad saying build
the dang fence build the dang wall and
then when President Trump said you know
what let's do that the people do want
that he fought tooth and nail against
that he was censured by the Republican
party here I know that on a world stage
many people know him but a lot of
Republicans in Arizona felt like he
showed up for a few months every six
years to run for re-election and then
ignored a lot of the issues facing
Arizona
you should be free from criticism okay I
completely agree no one should be free
from criticism I think it was the
juxtaposition I know I haven't been I
haven't been and I'm going to come to
that but I think the only point I would
make is you were so
praiseworthy of him in his death and yet
very soon after that suddenly it looked
like you turned on him
well Pierce really honestly
someone has just passed away and he had
La he led he's an icon LED an amazing
life I said the Maverick has passed away
and that was that was his uh his
nickname as you know because you've
interviewed him
I have a heart and a soul and I know the
suffering of losing a father I lost my
father more than a decade ago and I I
still
um tear up at the thought of of that and
I feel for the family I'm a human being
and so are they and I feel for that I've
not been unfairly critical of of John
McCain I think I've any criticism I've
launched at him was that he didn't do
what he told the people he would do and
I am not out to get anybody I actually
brought a lot of the Republican party
together I'm an America First Republican
we have McCain Republicans here and I
believe that we can work together we
agree a 95 of everything maybe 99 of
everything we Republicans do and we we
tend to kind of Duke things out and
debate and and I wish that okay what
about the other party did that okay they
just fall in line to one thing which is
spitting the party and that is this
issue of stolen elections so you've been
obviously Donald Trump support supported
you and you've been very supportive of
his belief that he had the 2020 election
stolen from him I've interviewed Donald
Trump and we had a great interview but I
took him on and said I don't think that
election was stolen from you and more
than that President Trump I think your
persistence in claiming it was is
damaging to your chances of potentially
winning again and I would say to you
Carrie Lee you're clearly a rising star
in the Republican firmament you've got a
lot of popularity in fact since you lost
the election and we'll come to whether
you think you have or not in a moment
but since you did a lot of money's come
in for you so people think Carrie late
Rising Star you know potentially on a
trump ticket who knows where that will
go and I'll ask you about that but you
again have not accepted the results of
the election and there is a belief that
it's almost deliberate it's like you've
looked at Donald Trump and thought you
know what there's a great way to make
money and fame for myself and that's to
be an election denier and I would simply
say to you I said to Donald Trump I
don't think it works for you guys I
don't think denying the result of
Democrats the election years is an
effective tool to actually win elections
that is the silliest thing I've ever
heard that is absolutely it's it's funny
actually I campaigned 525 days across
the most beautiful state in the country
Arizona and I know the people and I
worked incredibly hard and our
volunteers and the people gathered
around it it really was a movement and
you weren't here to cover it unlike
we've ever seen in politics
Gary of Arizona voter at sir sir 72
percent of Arizona voters believe that
that election something was wrong and it
wasn't honest 72 percent of arizonans
and I want to make sure I have children
I have two children 18 and 19 years old
I want to make sure when they grow up we
don't continue to run elections like a
Banana Republic we're on Election Day
voters showed up our voters showed up 75
to 25 3-1 on Election Day and the
machines weren't working they printed
intentionally the wrong image on the
ballot and that was meant to have the
ballot spit out and rejected by the
tabulators a quarter of a million times
on Election Day more than half of the
ballots were spit out
as you know has actually been there's
been millions
that way there's been no independent
corroboration that there was anything
fraudulent about this election in fact
it's pretty clear that you lost to Katie
Hobbs your your rival 50.3 to 49.6 and
as with Donald Trump and I said to
where's the hard evidence he went down
all sorts of rabbit holes but he
couldn't produce there's a ton of peers
peers there's there's there's a mountain
of Hard Evidence and when we presented
it in our trial the other side didn't
even dispute the evidence they didn't
they had but no one had the election
results
yes well we can't continue to run
elections this way and we know that we
won and we're going to continue to fight
this in a court of law and it's really
rich that you're sitting across the pond
acting like you know what happened on
Election Day I did not see your smiling
face we had lots of international media
here covering election day in Arizona
yours is one face I didn't see in nor
did I see it you could have had my
smiling face arizonans
I would have loved to have seen you we
had more media covering our election
than I've ever seen cover any any story
here in Arizona and as I said I covered
Arizona for nearly 30 years so it's okay
that you are not comfortable with me
fighting this election and fighting for
election Integrity
let me clarify I don't I don't mind your
fighting spirit I Don't Mind Donald
Trump I've known him a long time well I
have every right to fight this election
absolutely right there does come a point
it does come a point when for the future
of democracy you and Donald Trump have
to accept at some point you lost an
election otherwise the entire system
collapses if your simple response to
losing is always we didn't lose we won
then democracy dies
Pierce I grew up in a family of nine I'm
the youngest my father was a history and
government teacher and a football coach
and he taught us that if we lose and we
lose fair and square we we congratulate
the winner we walk away
and that's exactly what I would do if
that was a fair and square election but
I'm fighting for the people of Arizona I
go all over this country I've been
probably to Six States since the
election in Arizona I can't walk 10 feet
without an arizonan saying I voted for
you everybody I know voted for you our
ballot was rejected on Election Day
please keep fighting for us I'm fighting
for the people of Arizona and I I don't
mean any offense to you but I frankly
don't give a damn what you think about
it I'm fighting for the people of
Arizona I truly am no offense taken
whatsoever let me ask you this Pierce
let me ask let me ask you a question do
you think it's right that you show up on
Election Day that's the big day on
Election Day and 60 of the voting
locations in the primarily Republican
locations have ballots that are printed
out wrong listen sorry machines
is that okay all I know from my lofty
place here in London and I wasn't in
Arizona all I know is all the official
fact-checking entities that have looked
into all the claims do not conclude we
know
come on
Pierce Pierce did you just fall off the
turnip truck we know about the fact
Checkers and we've seen them this has
all been revealed half of them are
leftists working for Facebook let's
let's be real okay
one final Point what did they know what
do they know
at what point would you accept that
you've lost
well we're do you think that we have a
right to move this through the court
system I think we do I know that we do
we have the rights
but my point is indeed is there any
point you've got a right to do it is
there any point where you would accept
that you lost
we are taking it to the Supreme Court
that's where we're taking it okay let me
ask you secondly a lot of rumor swelling
you might run to be Senator is that true
I have had many people reach out to me
and say you need to run for Senator we
have an opportunity here to win uh and
we're we're really concerned about what
would happen if we allow a socialist
like the Democrat who's jumped in or
someone like Kirsten Cinema who votes
with Joe Biden 95 93 of the time we need
to have someone like you run you're the
only Republican who can win uh it is in
the back of my mind but my number one
priority is my case and I want to see my
case through I need Donald Trump if
Donald Trump says to you he wants you to
be his running mate what would your
answer be
wow the hypotheticals this is crazy
if the royal family invites you in and
offers you a job what are you going to
do Pierce I mean these are hypotheticals
I'd say yes thanks thanks very much when
do I start where's my Palace
well I honest honest to goodness I have
not given that thought and and I think
the president's amazing who's a great
president greatest of my lifetime and I
know that every American was doing
better when he was in the white house
and I really miss the economy that he
helped lead I miss the fact that he
helped to uh end Wars rather than start
wars first president in my lifetime that
didn't start a war and I know that he
cares deeply about this country we we
really need to get back to putting the
people of this country first giving them
back their government and I am um I am
just focused on what I'm doing here in
Arizona to be honest a final question on
Ukraine uh president zielinski's here in
London gave a stirring speech to
Parliament
um I'm curious why so many Republicans
seem to want Vladimir Putin to win
you know why don't you ask them
what's your view all I know is I am I am
here in Arizona and it is uh nothing is
more aggravating and
um anger inducing to the people of
Arizona then watching these buffoons
back in Washington DC take our
hard-earned money and write a check to
Ukraine over a hundred billion dollars
has gone to Ukraine and we sit here in
Arizona with a wide open border the
Narco terrorists and the drug cartels
with the help of the CCP in China are
pushing in and funneling record numbers
record amounts of fentanyl through
Arizona into the rest of this country
we're watching a Young Generation but
all those people
we have a wide open border and they
don't want to send but Carrie I don't
they don't want to send a penny here I
don't disagree with you about those
issues and they have to be tackable they
have nothing to do with Ukraine and
again my curiosity is simply that when
Saddam Hussein invaded Kuwait for
example I'm America couldn't wait to get
stuck in to kick him out and was and
most Republicans I know supported it and
yet here we have Vladimir Putin who is
on a whole different level of dictator
marching into a European country and to
my astonishment some Republicans seem to
think that the best answer to this is to
let him just take Ukraine and I'm just
bemused why why wouldn't every fiber of
a republican being be we have got to
defeat Putin wherever he he marches in
and tries to thwart democracy
well this Republican believes that we
need to make sure we're putting the
needs of Americans first and right now
Americans are struggling I've talked to
retirees who saved and did everything
right many of them were even veterans
they did everything right and they're
watching their retirement savings
evaporate under Joe Biden my focus is on
the people the good people of Arizona
and that's why I'm fighting for them
every day I continue to fight I watch
the people who are sitting in office
here and they are dead set on destroying
this state and making our lives making
us suffer and making us less safe so my
focus is on the people of Arizona and I
intend to keep my focus here we
oftentimes get involved in in skirmishes
and wars and try to start things up
overseas and I think the American people
are growing very weary of that
incredibly weary watching our
hard-earned money go overseas and we're
in a precarious spot if we continue to
behave that way and I don't think that's
the American Spirit okay well Carrie on
that we will disagree but it's been
great to interview thank you for coming
on Piers Morgan uncensored and I will
follow your your Rising career with
great interest
and please come to Arizona I would love
to tour you uh give you a tour of the
border and show you around and and maybe
we could even sit down and have lunch
and go over some of the evidence in our
case I would love to do that actually
I'll take you up on that Carrie Lake
thank you very much indeed
thank you pierce
well coming next to like the Church of
England's considering scrapping
centuries of religious teaching to give
God gender-neutral pronouns is our
heavenly father no more
foreign
[Music]
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Feltz on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
foreign
virginity in a field behind a pub
Sasha Walpole kept Harry Seeker for 21
years and then Harry told his truth and
his explosive Memoir and that included
her so now it's Sasha's turn to tell her
truth
and a Global TV exclusive she'll join me
on Piers Morgan uncensored and I
guarantee the interview will last a
little longer than Harry did
[Music]
thank you
foreign
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel nobody
is uh every little helps for God's sake
is nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it well that one too
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
next tonight let us pray Our Father
sorry not anymore our non-gendered
parent Who Art in Heaven does that sound
right to you and to break the centuries
of tradition the Church of England's
debating was to stop referring to God as
a he by introducing gender-neutral
pronouns in prayers and hymns while I'm
joined by Christian activist and author
Simon Hill and U.S conservative talk
radio host Ben Ferguson so Ben Ferguson
I'd imagine when you heard about this
the steam began to rage out of your ears
what is your view of a gender-neutral
god
congratulations to the church for doing
everything possible to become completely
irrelevant from society with this woke
BS it's embarrassing that they can't go
back and look at what scripture says and
look at certain things like Our Father
Who Art in Heaven and then sit there and
think wow of all the problems that
people have in the world that we could
be helping people with poverty and with
children with orphans and when people
are starving around the world let's go
back in and rewrite this so that we
don't offend anybody guess what the
scriptures are offensive to people that
sin the scriptures are offensive to
Christians because it is about right and
wrong there are people that are always
going to be offended by the Bible and to
try to take the offensiveness out of it
and give everybody a Kumbaya warm hug is
a disaster for the church anyone that's
doing this in my opinion should not be
in a position of leadership of the
church and they should be fired
immediately for trying it okay
Simon Hill your response to that
well I think with all respect to Ben
he's right that the church should be
concerned about poverty about the needs
of children the church could get a lot
more active in supporting marginalized
people but this isn't the Church of
England considering a massive change
this is just a part of the Church of
England having a discussion about
possibly allowing some variety In
Worship in the way God is referred to
and actually there's nothing new about
it God is not literally male or
literally oh God that's what we're
talking about or chromosomes
um God you're not suggesting Ben are you
that God is actually not a pretty male
like are you are you
okay let me ask you a question am I a
serious question am I black
I don't know I can't see you I'm just
talking down on a microphone
and I am male am I a male or a female
serious question
well I assuming you mail from what you
say
um of course Jesus okay so if you don't
be that logical if you hold on one
second if you can be that logical and
I'll go to Pierce Morgan for this is is
Piers Morgan black or white
well I'm currently identifying his wife
and Pierce is white God is not good okay
this is the insanity the the fact that
we're even having a pause and people are
worried about how to answer the damn
question is the absurdity of what's
going on in this world peers just so you
know I have no problem saying you're
white I have no problem saying that
you're not Roy McElroy I have no problem
saying that you're not a woman I have no
problem saying that you're not Jesus I
have no problem saying that there's a
difference between a man and woman there
shouldn't be a long pause because we're
afraid of offending someone when we tell
them the truth the fact is there are
certain things that are just straight
all right yes Jesus is amazing
response
Simon is simply that I can imagine that
a lot of people in England who are
Christian who've you know who've seen
this headline particularly The Daily
Mail the front page is God going to go
gender-neutral they'll just groan out
loud and they will think the Church of
England has gone on woke and as we know
once that starts it just starts to
alienate people from the church and at a
time when the church needs more support
not less support I'm surprised they
would want to press the woke button
and I groaned when I saw the Daily Mail
headline because it was so inaccurate
because it suggested this was going to
be some major change in the Church of
England rather than a committee having a
discussion about some possible minor
changes it may alienate you for the
church to try to be inclusive but
actually
this is challenging if we can you know
I'm happy to call God he or she or they
what would you do with the Lord and out
of Interest what would you what would
you do Simon with the Lord's Prayer you
can't start with our father I still say
I still say I still say our father but
why why would you do that if you believe
in genes that refer to God as mother
yeah but hang on if you believe in
gender neutrality uh for God why would
you start the Lord's Prayer with our
father that makes no sense obviously you
have to change it to our person well I'd
happy to say father or mother because I
think God is our father and our mother I
and as I say there are prayers
every Church everywhere I go where
there's a church setting you say the
Lord's Prayer right are you now saying
we change the wording of the Lord's
Prayer to our mother who aren't in
heaven is that what you're suggesting no
I'm not saying that at all what do
people do they don't say you're saying
the male headline is wrong and I'm
saying to you oh someone who worked in
the mail for a long time is it wrong
isn't it the natural extension of where
this debate goes which is actually what
the daily mail but everything could be
changed in the church
right so just to clarify what Jesus
referred to God as right I understand
let me just ask the question just to
clarify so that everyone watching is
it's under No Illusion what this means
if God is deemed to be gender neutral
what are the is the wording to the start
of the Lord's Prayer what how do we
start it
I think it's fine to refer to God as
father or mother or parent I don't think
that have you been to a church
in Heaven Simon have you been to one
that did that I've been to a church
service that said our parent yes but our
mother
um not in the Lord's Prayer but in other
prayers I've LED prayers in church right
I mean the Lord's Prayer is the most
important prayer of all we know that in
the Christian no no what makes a prayer
important is the sincerity in our hearts
no what is sincere about it
what's sincere about changing the
wording after centuries of this Keen key
prayer in the Christians from Our Father
Who Art in Heaven
to me to me the problem with this Ben is
it makes no sense like a lot of woke
things it all sounds great it's
inclusive
this is something Simon hang on I'm
asking Ben the problem is but when you
go down this woke Rabbit Hole it sounds
great in principle yeah let's be more
inclusive until you get to the actual
details I.E what is the wording of the
Lord's Prayer and when I hear it it
might be our parents who art in heaven
or our mother who art in heaven like let
me tell you my mother a Catholic
watching this at home will be throwing
stuff at the screen
yeah if you want to destroy religion
this is how you do it let me finish let
me finish if you want to destroy
people's faith and God this is how you
do it if you want to destroy the church
this is how you destroy it and that may
be what some people are wanting to do
here through wokeness is say we stand
for nothing to include everything and we
don't stand up for right and wrong
because ultimately if you look at what
the Bible is about nothing to do what
people believe in it's about let me
finish let me finish okay just hold on I
I was quiet for quite some time and
Pierce knows me well that was very hard
for me very unusual the church is about
right and wrong and and good and evil
and and if you take that away where the
church can no longer stand up for what
is right and have principles and declare
that things are in fact wrong you will
destroy the church and you will destroy
a society who has no faith in anything
has no faith in God it's going to be
where they go with it it's an
interesting debate assignment appreciate
you joining me Ben thank you for joining
me and letting Ben get a word in it I'm
not denying right and wrong
all right but so I'm Gonna Leave You all
right thank you very much you can't even
tell me what a man or a woman is guys on
that bombshell thank you very much you
didn't actually ask me that but I
believe in principles I don't believe
God is a man in the sky I I do think if
we're going to start the Lord's Prayer
with our mother who lives
guys gotta leave it there thank you very
much indeed coming up Madonna is always
Reinventing herself now she's declared
herself a victim of ageism and misogyny
all because people were mocking her face
at the Grammys which certainly born
their relation to the face you used to
have and we'll debate that next
foreign
[Music]
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Felts is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
what she's the older woman who took
Prince Harry's virginity in a field
behind a pub
Sasha Walpole kept Harry Seeker for 21
years and then Harry told his truth in
his explosive Memoir and that included
her so now Sasha's turn to tell her
truth
and a Global TV exclusive she'll join me
on Piers Morgan uncensored and I
guarantee the interview will last a
little longer than Harry did
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy
speechwriters here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it what
that one too
[Music]
this is talk TV
well one of these stand-up moments for
me the Grammy Awards we're not the
actual Awards themselves but this
Madonna looking like she got the wrong
date for Halloween well now she's taken
to Instagram to say many people chose
only to talk about close-up photos of me
God forbid that anyone would photograph
Madonna taken with a long lens camera by
a press photographer that would distort
anyone's face once again I'm called in
the glare of ageism and misogyny that
permeates the world we live in a world
that refuses to celebrate women past the
age of 45. well they just discuss this
podcast from comedian James Barr talked
to be contributor Esther Krakow
Associated to the Daily Mirror Kevin
McGuire so Kevin I woke up this morning
to Madonna because I had past comment of
the critical nature about Madonna and
she tweeted the world is threatened by
my power and my stamina my intelligence
and my will to survive but they will
never break me this is all the tests and
there was a very filtered picture of
herself which had clearly been through
the filtering minister so here's about
think about Madonna Kevin
I think she is an absolute joke now and
I say that as somebody who was a massive
fan I literally went to see her on the
Holiday Tour one of the greatest pop
stars at her Peak I've ever seen she has
become an embarrassing shambles quite
deliberately and I when I saw these
pictures I just I once again thought my
God what did she a what she done to
herself but B the constant attention
thinking she was making horrible sexual
signs with Sam Smith they she was doing
all sorts of stuff his normal you know
the normal attention seeking and it just
doesn't the ACT doesn't play when you're
in the mid 60s would you have been
outraged if Mick Jagger was doing that I
had the same way I mean he doesn't do
what she does yeah but it's come on she
is a victim of ageism but at the same
time she's a victim of her own number
she's always out there trying to get
noticed and if you go out there and try
and get noticed you're going to get
jeers as well you're a self-confessed
Madonna super fat yes is she is she a
victim of ageism and misogynist
absolutely and the fact that we're sat
here two men sat here discussed three
men discussing misogyny is misogynistic
so Kevin is just women you don't get an
opinion on whether Madonna is telling
her truth or not that's her what is her
truth that people are being misogynistic
and that a woman over reported drive is
not allowed or permitted to be set sorry
there is in the eyes of people like you
there is only there is only the truth
there's not people's versions of it
we're not on the Megan and Harry podcast
right so you can't just say her true no
there are facts the fact is she's done
stuff to her face surgically which means
when she goes out now we all shriek in
horror I think it's quite rude to say
that you shriek in horror I literally
did and like a Halloween costume but
ultimately appears that you've met
Madonna you you called her rude she was
incredibly rude every time but I don't
hold that against her but it sounds like
you do actually wrong women are allowed
to be they're allowed to be rude little
madams and she is right no problem at
all women are allowed to not like you
people absolutely if it doesn't give you
permission
meaning it's not a problem at all she
can hate my guts it doesn't mean I can't
pass comment on her without being called
immediately misogynist but is anyone
discussing how you look and all the time
literally I get fat shamed all the time
even though as you can see I'm basically
emaciated right okay so so and this is
the new regime by the way it's a new
year new me and it's all just falling
off so yeah um sure but I you know why
because I got a vaccine I actually think
it's good I'm Donald needs to listen to
proper friends you say to her what the
hell are you doing to your face love
right look at that it's like the Bride
of we'll just eat it's not misogyny to
notice that she looks crazy I'm a huge
Madonna say that she looks crazy well
she does look crazy
she looks terrible you look like a loaf
of orbitants like if she was my friend
seriously I think the issue here is
she's too rich to be looking this crazy
I have no problem with cosmetic surgery
there are loads of celebrities I've had
it done the aim is not to look crazy I'm
a huge fan of and I just think she's too
established she's too much of an icon to
do this
to notice is that she's telling you why
perhaps in your opinion she looks the
way she looks and she's being a victim
it's not crazy
even you don't think she's I do think a
lot of misogyny of ageism of people like
you saying she literally seeing that
she's not permitted to be sexy in her
60s
I just said that when someone is that
desperate she releases picture after
picture of herself naked lying under
beds you know all sorts of kissing toy
boys it's all attention seeking
narcissism fine what you can't do is
look at this picture here now the idea
the idea I can't criticize that picture
is say that is desperate a woman in the
60s I mean without you saying you're
being ages to misogynist no I'm not
James Barr look at her she's hot that's
a hot piece of that I mean that looks
like a dead cockroach
that was your great grandma which by the
way she's old enough to be honestly like
a it's like it looks like a crime scene
doesn't it that's what it does yeah
I don't know if your grandparents are
still alive no sadly my nan is not here
but imagine if she wasn't that was her
and she released that picture I would
love that really yeah I've got friends
whose grandmas are on only fans
I'd have to have a quiet what right well
I think you'd probably be feeling a
little uncomfortable but mainly because
you might be finding it attractive
here's my point I don't think you can
behave the way Madonna behaves and not
expect criticism so then play the victim
when you deliberately provoke people if
I think you'd have said it would be like
me playing the victim but I give it out
large with my opinions and then say and
someone says to me oh stop being so
disgusting oh my God I'm a victim
look I see a lot of it is embarrassing I
look at Helen Miller who I think it must
be a bit older and is really in a very
different way
but some of the criticism she gets is
motivated because of her age and because
she's the one once because she gets more
because she practices she wants to play
the 25 year old sexy and she's 64. right
and I'm sorry Esther but I would say
there's something about mate Jaguar when
he's ever done it the old you know
strolling bone thing on stage he's like
come on babe you need to stop having
children um look I I don't think it's a
misogyny to notice when someone's acting
acting nice right or looking
she is Madonna she's an icon she will
always be an icon this is completely be
unnecessary and it's not ages and more
sexism or misogyny to notice that this
isn't necessary but by the way look look
James here's the point you've bought
tickets to a concert millions of other
people have and will it'll be a Smash
Hit she's not a victim she might be many
other things but all this does is fuel
this sort of Fury around Madonna and
she'll make even more money and sell
even more tickets but it's just the
playing the victim which got my goat
this morning it's like Madonna of all
things stick it back to me call me a
rough Old English twerk whatever you
want to call me I don't care I don't
care but don't play the victim because
it's pathetic I don't think it's
pathetic that she's just sold out a
world tour of 30 plus dates in seconds I
don't think that's I think it's
absolutely baffling but if you want to
go and watch her prancing around in her
60s looking like that enjoy your show
James thank you so much you're getting
the words of Madonna there's no greater
power than the power of goodbye indeed
James goodbye
that seems totally immaterial girl uh
anyway yeah
[Laughter]
Prince Harry told the world about the
woman who took his because you didn't
see his settle a book he invaded their
privacy and now it's her turn a taste of
my Global TV exclusive is coming up
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
foreign
politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
what she's the older woman who took
Prince Harry's virginity in a field
behind a pub
Sasha Walpole kept Harry Seeker for 21
years and then Harry told his truth and
his explosive Memoir and that included
her so now Sasha's turn to tell her
truth
and a Global TV exclusive she'll join me
on Piers Morgan uncensored and I
guarantee the interview will last a
little longer than Harry did
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no out with the people's Channel nobody
is uh every little helps for God's sake
is nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it well that one too
[Music]
thank you
welcome back and we'll cover an Astra
still here let's talk about zelenski a
pretty powerful speech today Kevin
whatever side you are on about all this
I just thought he really is an amazing
orator yeah is the real deal stole the
show spoke in English uh you know
whether he did a broadcast opponent the
last time it was in Ukrainian but what I
like though is he is there yep he said
thank you but he made a request he wants
plane yeah wings for Freedom he said
he's not afraid to come and raise the
ante every time and some interesting
politics Esther because Boris Johnson
was there on the sort of seen muscling
his way to the front of the thing but
actually it was really about Rishi
Sunnet because he's the Prime Minister
and this was I think rishi's way
obviously I interviewed him last week
and asked him about whether he's worried
about being called a submarine prime
minister by Nadine Doris when she had to
be Boris for tall TV and it looks to me
like he's decided right enough of Boris
zipping off to Ukraine every 10 minutes
pretending he's still prime minister I'm
going to host him here and show him the
red carpet which he did and I think it
was an impressive day for both of them
actually and I can only hope Boris will
finally Take a Hint
um because obviously and take due credit
as zelenski gave Boris exactly but for
getting the sort of Coalition of support
together but right now this is about
Rishi sunec by Johnson yeah calls the
shots now he'll decide whether he gets
planes or not not Johnson I mean I find
it interesting the petty politics people
are playing with zelinski's outfit oh
that's ridiculous I've seen people
tweeting they're like why does he always
wear a military so why do you think he's
a what is it a country at War yeah the
second time he's left the country right
it's nearly a year this has been raging
I mean when you go and meet zelenskis I
did in Ukraine in Kiev he's such an
impressive guy he's really quite a short
guy you know he does not he's not
physically like a big sort of presence
but when you talk to him he feels like
he grows in front of you yeah he's got
such uh eloquence the way he expresses
himself such resilience and kind of
determination to win this and I think a
bit like Churchill in World War II for
us in a way he's helped persuade the
Ukrainian people we can we can win this
yeah expect this I think people forget
that you know at no point in this
presidency did he think you know I would
be leading the country during a conflict
with Russia for a year right right so I
think people need to understand he
really has the weight of an entire
nation on his shoulders so nitpicking on
things like his image and all of that
it's very Petty and it's also losing
sight of the bigger issue Russia will
not stop at Ukraine I think for us to
forget that is irresponsible yeah I do
find it weird Kevin that Republicans
which we carry Lakers play a rising star
on the party but there is a real
sentiment now amongst Republicans that
they should be almost pulling out of
Ukraine and you think why would you why
would an old school Republican an
American want a dictator like Putin to
win I don't care about it it's America
looking inwards again America first as
everybody else last and I think it's a
really worrying uh development in the
U.S are you surprised I think it's
misplaced um kind of in internal like
looking internally because I think the
argument should be how do we wrap this
war up as quickly as possible Right but
then you have this kind of rabid wing of
the Republican Party they're just like
no let's just pull out entirely I was
like you're not really understanding the
nuances of the situation yeah you should
want to this war to wrap up very quickly
because it affects everyone you should
want to you know fast conclusion not
let's pull out immediately right
umski also met King Charles at
Buckingham Palace obviously coronation
coming up
um you know it was a nice meeting of
these two people
um and he made a nice line zelenski
about all the pilots now in in Ukraine
our Kings to him yeah and he presented
actually a pilot's helmet didn't need it
in in Parliament
um but a big few weeks and months coming
up for King Charles leading up to this
coronation Kevin it's a big moment for
him for the country for the monarchy and
of course but for you personally people
leaving the country as a report I'm
actually thinking of going here I am
actually thinking of going away to miss
it but for him it it is huge of course
he's got it he's got work out what is he
going to do with his own family yeah and
you've got the Andrew Scandal still
there and some of his mates seem to be
pushing that he's really you know the
Dreyfus of uh and then you've got Harry
and he can't ignore that right well you
certainly can't ignore the interview
that we have tomorrow night because we
have the first television interview in
the world with the lady who took Harry's
virginity uh and we've got a little clip
from this this is Sasha Walpole from my
interview which is airing tomorrow night
people are asking you know family and
friends oh yeah we know who it is and
then suddenly it's just the reality of
this isn't going to go away forever this
is going to flare up until they know who
it is they're going to be questioning
people and yes I could not have said
anything but then it's never going to
stop this is I think he should have had
the the manners honestly to just have
let you know it was gonna be gonna give
me heads up of like you know I'm going
to put it in the book
it's an extraordinary interview with
somebody who we'd never heard of last
week and suddenly it's propelled into
the front pages of newspapers because
Harry ironically invaded her privacy and
put all the details about losing magenta
to this older woman in this Pub
everybody in the locality knew who he
was talking about and before she knew it
it was like an Unstoppable thing of
outing her so she thought I may as well
get ahead of it but the irony Esther of
Prince privacy making this woman feel
like had previously been invaded well
because he's not very intelligent
everyone knows that Prince Harry is
quite frankly a bit thick and he thought
he was being clever by by shrouding in
some sort of secrecy oh as an older
woman in a pub and I'm like you know
there are people there there are people
that can easily identify this moment the
situation and who was there well it's a
it's a it's a great interview we're
wearing it tomorrow night if you want to
find out what he thinks about Harry uh
she thinks about Harry now about Meghan
Markle about King Charles it's all in
this interview with Sasha Walpole as
exclusive tomorrow night the lady who
took Harry's virginity my only talking
about it because he did that's it for us
tonight uncensored keep it that way good
night
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
foreign
who took Prince Harry's virginity in a
field behind a pub
Sasha Walpole kept Harry Seeker for 21
years but then Harry told his truth in
his explosive Memoir and that included
her so now Sasha's turn to tell her
truth
and a Global TV exclusive she'll join me
on Piers Morgan uncensored and I
guarantee the interview will last a
little longer than Harry did
[Music]